thanks to Reddit and R movies we've just
had a list of the top 10 most realistic
Sci-Fi movies ever made but is the list
any good I've got a few quite big
problems with it welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
so let's not mess about let's get
straight into the list so number 10
arrival 2016 starring Amy Adams now
actually that's a pretty good film I
don't mind this on this list the reason
why I liked it so much so it was a
really focused on communication and the
problems we'd have if we actually met an
alien race with communicating with them
the meaning of language and what it
actually does to us what it means to us
how it shapes our thinking was really a
central part of this movie it made for a
slightly boring movie at times but from
a realism point of view and actually the
problems we're gonna have when we do
meet an alien race yeah it was really
really fascinating number nine the
Martian in 2015 this film blew me away
I just thought Matt Damon was brilliant
in it I thought it was a very clever
movie I thought it was really funny
according to Neil Degrassi Tyson this
film was actually the most realistic
sci-fi movie that he's ever seen and
then actually it ties in with what is
scientifically possible now that's going
to be one of my first problems this is
supposed to be sci-fi
I'm not sure the Martian is sci-fi but
at the end of the day we're not able to
go to Mars today so yeah it squeaks
through
2001 A Space Odyssey by Stanley Kubrick
back in 1968 gets in at number eight now
apparently NASA did actually get
involved in big passes movies and they
did consult on it and they tried to make
it again as realistic as possible
there's nothing really in the movie
that's a major problem they do mention
one of the Reddit people do mention that
actually he's drinking a drink through a
straw and when he stops sucking the
liquid goes back down other than that
there aren't any actual scientific
errors in the movie I think we can
actually let that one slide
but yeah again a great movie
why not number seven was 1971's The
Andromeda Strain
a simple premise a space probe brings a
virus back down to earth and they're
desperately trying to prevent it
spreading it's a simple idea it's a very
plausible idea and it's a movie that
really made us think about the
scientific possibilities and you know
that we need safeguards against
unchecked scientific possibilities
because when science goes too far that's
when Terminator happens number six is
1997's Gatica now if I don't know
Thurman in it I love Uma Thurman she's
lovely it had Ethan Hawke in it great
actor
it's a dystopian future I'm already
feeling sleepy I actually have watched
the film once
I think I might have fell asleep it
might be a realistic movie it might ask
lots of very important questions about
identity and things but for me it's a
slightly boring movie but yeah it's
still sci-fi so okay realistic
I love these films actually are a little
boring
2013's her never watched it but that got
to number five can't really say anything
intelligent about it 2021 stowaway in
number four now this is another movie
that I'm going to question whether it's
actually sci-fi because I have to say
and I'm going to talk about this at the
end of the video because I'm going to
have a massive rant about it
but this film is scientifically
plausible it's in that we could possibly
do it today now this movie was about how
there's a three-man mission going to
Mars and somebody stole the board and he
up a lot of the life support and
then they are basically trying to
survive it reminded me of Apollo 13 and
which again not a science fiction movie
because it actually happened just
because it happens in space does not
make it sci-fi it really did again raise
lots of moral questions about the
decisions and the difficulties of
operating in space and how you know when
something goes wrong you might have to
make some decisions that are morally
questionable but if you're going to
survive or the mission is going to
survive they need to be asked so yeah an
interesting movie that I I'm glad to see
on the list number three Minority Report
now Stephen Spielberg said when he did
this film he wanted all of the toys in
the movie to be at least somewhere in
realistic he wanted them all to be
available someday and in lots of ways
you know he managed that the um I mean
we're starting to get electronic drones
and stuff that police ride and stuff in
like Abu Dhabi and places we're starting
to get some of the weapons and things I
would argue though that the movie is
based around basically psychics that
could see the future I'm going to
question whether that's based in any
sort of science
but as a realistic movie and actually as
a fun movie I loved Minority Report I
thought it was a great film I I do have
a bit of a love-hate relationship with
Tom Cruise I'll admit but this is one of
his better ones uh Spielberg I thought
delivered a really realistic movie and I
think yeah number three fantastic the
film in at number two is a film
with because it's very often called the
most realistic sci-fi movie ever made
but I argue that even though the end is
based on sort of some theories of
quantum mechanics it's not scientific
it's not believable or realistic and it
really does wander into fantasy very
heavily
the movie Interstellar is very popular
with lots of science fiction fans I
didn't get it I'm not a big fan of
Christopher Norman I don't like his um
movie style that tenant movie he did was
crap but hey at least in this movie when
they were talking about a black hole
they actually treated it correctly and
didn't try to use it as a gateway to
another Universe Star Trek so
yeah okay on that one I give it that and
a in Parts it's a really enjoyable movie
and I really love sort of like the
issues at the start of the movie with
you know the crop failing and things
like this and a lot of the Technologies
even though the robot made no sense to
me a lot of the Technologies were
realistic
number one
is not a sci-fi movie
I don't care what anybody says
2013's gravity with Sandra Bullock and
George Clooney is not a sci-fi movie
NASA astronaut Michael J Massimo said
that nothing was out of place there was
a wire cutter we use the spacewalks and
it actually is a wire cutter they used
in the movie
um one of the Reddit people said hey an
unlikely set of events was
scientifically plausible not
scientifically plausible scientifically
doable I mean I know a lot of this stuff
was that she a lot of stuff didn't
actually happen that was extraordinary
George Clooney ended up hitting the
spaceship after going all the way around
here it didn't happen she imagined it
but everything happens in the film is
scientifically not just plausible it's
realistic in that it would be real
so let's have a quick look at the
definition of Science Fiction so from
the Oxford dictionary this is the
definition fiction based on imagined
future scientific or technological
advances and a major social or
environmental changes frequently
portraying space or time travel and life
on other planets
what in the movie of gravity with Sandra
Bullock who's lovely is
future Scientific Technology none it
wasn't it was all completely doable
Scientific Technology of today
major social environmental changes nope
she's just in a rocket on her own
um it features space but just because
it's in space does not mean it's science
fiction which I think is maybe where the
confusions come from time travel no
it's it's not sci-fi
so guys I want you to ever think that
about what is a realistic sci-fi
I think I'm gonna put together my own
list of the top 10 most realistic Sci-Fi
movies and I'm gonna say that they have
to be science fiction but by realistic
they have to be technologies that are
within the realm of possibility to
create not create today like gravity or
even really the Martian even though that
probably will make my list because it is
still science fiction
because we haven't been to Mars and
actually we couldn't right now so
science fiction guys I'd love to know
exactly what you think and will you help
me put this list together
what are the top 10 most realistic
Sci-Fi movies please get into the
comments and start you don't have to do
a top 10 just start throwing some movies
in there and then next week I will do a
proper list of the top 10 most realistic
Sci-Fi movies
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
or soon go to patreon.com forward slash
sidetrackware for a small contribution
each month that really supports the
channel you get to see most of our
videos first and without the adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll
catch you next time
[Music]